los partidos políticos portugueses se
enfrentan por última vez previo a unas
reñidas elecciones que se desarrollarán
el domingo el primer ministro de
portugal antonio costa y sus oponentes
se reunieron el viernes en lisboa el
funcionario de centroizquierda dejó
claro que un voto a favor del partido
socialista
significaba que no habría posibilidad de
un acuerdo con el partido de extrema
derecha llega no nunca dependeremos de
chica para nada para nada para nada para
nada
llega que se traduce como basta ha ido
ganando apoyo desde que el partido de
extrema derecha se formó en 2019 este
año obtuvieron un escaño en el parlament
o algo inédito para un partido de
extrema derecha desde que terminó la
dictadura de portugal en
1974 el líder de llega andrew ventura
habló de un apoyo creciente ya que las
encuestas sugieren que podría
convertirse en el tercer partido más
grande costa ha dicho a los votantes que
la oposición socialdemócrata de
centroderecha o ps de podrían ser
rehenes de llega en caso de ganar la
mayoría dijo que probablemente
necesitarían el apoyo del par de extrema
derecha para aprobar las leyes el líder
socialdemócrata y el alcalde de oporto
se ha centrado en una nueva dirección
para portugal
para sustituir a antónio costa solo hay
un voto posible y ese voto es para el
partido socialdemócrata
las elecciones anticipadas del domingo
fueron convocadas en noviembre después
de que dos partidos de extrema izquierda
se pusieran del lado de la derecha para
rechazar el proyecto de presupuesto del
primer ministro para 2022 los sondeos
pronostican una carrera reñida entre
costa y río y el resultado podría
reflejar los avances de la ultraderecha
en otros lugares de europa